oggi vi invito all'interno di un viaggio
un viaggio che richiede Però da parte
vostra un piccolo sforzo ovvero
immaginare una laguna di Venezia senza
però la sua protagonista ovvero senza
Venezia il periodo storico che andremo a
vedere oggi è un periodo storico nel
quale il campanile di San Marco non
esiste la Basilica di San Marco non
esiste l'Arsenale non esiste il ponte di
Rialto non esiste Quindi tutta una serie
di elementi caratterizzanti la città di
Venezia che non esistono Insomma un
periodo storico nel quale la città di
Venezia non esiste Ma allora chi è che
agiva all'interno di questo territorio
Chi è che operava chi è che ne sfruttava
le risorse all'interno di questa laguna
questa che possiamo vedere è una pianta
che racconta come era strutturata la
laguna circa duemila anni fa e c'è una
grande Assente la città di Venezia la
cui forma
riesce così come la conosciamo in realtà
appartiene all'ottavo IX secolo C'è poi
un ulteriore grande assente che è il
litorale di Punta Sabbioni luogo oggi
Dove appunto pullulano campeggi e
alberghi il limite tra il mare e la
laguna è un limite caratterizzato dalle
isole di lioco piccolo gli omaggiore da
Sant'Erasmo quindi lo spazio acqueo è
leggermente più piccolo più che di
Laguna in realtà potremmo parlare di
Golfo siamo quindi dinanzi ad un Golfo
ma un Golfo di chi chi è che opera
all'interno di questo Golfo Chi è che ne
gestisce le acque che ne sfrutta tutte
le risorse
una città che è sulla gronda Lagunare e
che avrà una storia bellissima Ovvero la
città di Altino
Altino è una città che durante il primo
e secondo secolo dopo Cristo raggiunge
il suo Massimo splendore ed è a tutti
gli effetti una città romana è
costituita da un teatro da un anfiteatro
da un foro a tutti quegli elementi che
rendono romana è una città e la forma di
Altino è una forma che ricorda
dannatamente ciò che sarà poi Venezia
è
caratterizzata da una serie di canali
che quotidianamente vengono navigati da
mercanti da commercianti che entrano ed
escono costantemente all'interno della
città Altino poi ha anche un porto nella
zona sud meridionale e le attività
Dunque preponderanti sono legate
fondamentalmente alla presenza
l'elemento dell'acqua e quindi
le Saline quindi la pesca e quindi il
commercio Ma che tipo di acqua la laguna
di Venezia Scusate la laguna di Altino
di fronte appunto ad Altino è un tipo di
acqua che potremmo definire ibrida è un
tipo di acqua appunto salmastra cioè
costituita dall'acqua del mare che entra
in realtà come oggi no ogni 6 ore dalle
bocche di Porto e che esce Appunto ma
c'è anche un altro tipo di acqua che è
l'acqua portata dai fiumi Tenete
presente che siamo in un periodo storico
nel quale le grandi deviazioni fluviali
che avvengono durante la Repubblica di
Venezia non sono ancora state fatte
Quindi in realtà L'apporto costante
quotidiano che avviene da parte di
questi fiumi va a modellare la laguna e
arricchisce ovviamente di acqua dolce la
laguna stessa come sappiamo Insomma
immagino Ve lo ricordate anche delle
elementari i fiumi oltre a portare però
l'acqua dolce portano anche i sedimenti
portano Limo argilla portano sabbia
supportano tutta una serie di detriti
che vanno a modificare questo Golfo
vanno a modificare la laguna In realtà
però questi sedimenti prima di arrivare
in laguna possono anche fermarsi prima
possono fermarsi lungo i letti dei vari
canali e dei vari fiumi creando non
pochi problemi all'interno della
morfologia stessa della città di Altino
pensate che c'è una porta d'accesso alla
città una porta monumentale quindi
immaginatevi un ingresso enorme
all'interno di questa città che si
chiama porta Approdo che da un punto di
vista archeologico ha evidenziato come
nel giro di 80 anni nel momento in cui è
stata aperta è stata poi
defizionalizzata proprio a causa
dell'interramento questo problema Dunque
è un problema molto sentito dagli
altinati e molto probabilmente è un
problema che verrà anche a crearsi in
altre zone della città di Altino magari
nel centro storico della città del Tino
e magari anche nella zona Portuale di
Altino
capite bene però che se io ho un porto
interrato le navi che quotidianamente
possono entrare all'interno della città
hanno non pochi problemi in quanto anche
i prodotti che vengono a solitamente
arrivare all'interno della città stessa
non possono più arrivare Dunque
chiamiamola l'imprenditoria Altinate
dell'epoca e di fronte a un bivio o
indirizzarsi esclusivamente in un tipo
di Commercio terrestre Oppure trovare
una nuova rotta trovare un'altra area
portuale per poter continuare ad avere
questa vocazione Marittima che rende Tra
l'altro Altino una delle città più
importanti della decimareggio per questa
ragione gli altinati scelgono di
individuare un'altra area portuale una
nuova rotta portuale che appunto
all'isola di Torcello
Torcello È un luogo perfetto per questo
tipo di attività perché è capace non
solo di essere molto vicino al mare ma
al tempo stesso anche di essere vicino
ad Altino Quindi è un collegamento
magnifico Per quanto riguarda la
gestione delle merci voi vi dovete
immaginare tutta una serie di navi si
chiamano onerarie che arrivavano
nell'area torcellana e che un po' come
succede oggi con Amazon con grandi tir
no che arrivano all'interno di questi
centri di smistamento i prodotti ehm
vengono appunto inseriti all'interno di
piccoli furgoncini che poi raggiungono
le nostre case quindi è la stessa
identica cosa che capita in realtà in
epoca appunto tardo Antica queste Grandi
Navi arrivano a Torcello all'interno di
queste infrastrutture di questi
magazzini avviene la cosiddetta rottura
di carico e queste mercanzia poi vengono
date in queste imbarcazioni un pochino
più piccole che vengono chiamate
l'interesse che hanno degli scafi piatti
e che quindi da Torcello possono andare
direttamente all'interno del centro di
Altino è chiaro Dunque che
un'organizzazione infrastrutturale di
questo tipo prevede anche una serie di
lavoratori che possono operare
all'interno di quest'area
dei Mercanti delle degli operai
specializzati che ovviamente devono
sottostare a una sorta di autorità
un'autorità che non necessariamente
deve essere civile Tenete presente che
siamo in un'area che è ancora
Altino è la stessa identica cosa che
succede è anche con Marghera magari
Infatti è un quartiere periferico di
Venezia un quartiere industriale di
Venezia ma in realtà È pur sempre
Venezia è la stessa identica cosa accade
per Torcello Torcello pur essendo
un'area portuale è pur sempre e
periferica è pur sempre parte integrante
del territorio alti parte integrante che
però è gestita vi dicevo da un'autorità
che non necessariamente deve essere
civile ma è un'autorità che forse può
essere anche religiosa magari vescovile
e non è un caso che a partire dal
Settimo secolo quindi un secolo
successivo alla
creazione di questo porto di questi
magazzini legati appunto all'attività
Mercantile si vada a costituire la prima
fondazione della Basilica di Torcello
quindi il vescovo che in realtà è
autorità che gestisce non solo l'aspetto
religioso ma gestisce Anche l'aspetto
politico e commerciale all'interno di di
un territorio
capite bene che dopo tutto questo
presupposto la narrazione a cui Forse
siete stati abituati sono stato abituato
anch'io quando appunto andava a scuola
secondo la quale ehm la laguna di
Venezia all'isola di Torcello Venezia
stessa è stata abitata e sono
successivamente alle Invasioni barba
proteiche in quanto gli altinati No
comunque dalle varie città della Gronda
Lagunare queste persone scappano No dai
barbari brutti e cattivi in realtà deve
essere quantomeno ridimensionata non ci
sono dei trasferimenti immediati cotti a
seguito diciamo da un intervento da
parte appunto del nemico da parte dei
Barbari ma in realtà molto probabilmente
le motivazioni sono anche legate
all'ambiente sono legate all'ecologia
sono legate anche al regime dei fiumi
che tendono a interrare tutto il terreno
in tutto questo in tutta quest'orbita
diciamo Venezia dov'è che si inserisce
Venezia come vi dicevo ha una storia a
sé pensate che Venezia andrà a
interagire con Torcello solo a partire
dall'undicesimo secolo quindi in un
periodo molto più tardi rispetto al
periodo che abbiamo preso in
considerazione
e tra l'altro gli ultimi studi
dimostrano che la vita di Venezia possa
dipendere in realtà da una città che
diventerà poi la sua acerrima nemica
durante i secoli successivi durante
appunto la cosiddetta fase della
Serenissima Ovvero la città di Padova ma
questa è un'ulteriore nuova rotta
all'interno di un altro viaggio che
potremmo Poi un giorno affrontare Grazie
[Applauso]